>>> EXACTLY TEN WEEKS LEFT UNTIL
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS, AND RACES
ARE HEATING UP ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
SO IS AMERICA'S PARTISAN DIVIDE,
FORCING CANDIDATES TO THE
EXTREMES.
JOHN AVLON WITH OUR REALITY
CHECK.
>> SO THERE'S A FEEDBACK LOOP
BETWEEN THE FAR LEFT AND THE FAR
RIGHT THAT'S OFTEN USED TO
JUSTIFY THE OTHER'S RISE.
BECAUSE POLITICS IS PERCEPTION,
AMERICANS SEE BOTH PARTIES
SIMILARLY EXTREME.
BUT TO A LARGE EXTENT, THIS IS A
FIGHT IN A HALL OF MIRRORS, ALL
PARTISAN DISTORTION DRIVEN BY
EMOTION.
THE FACT IS THAT THE FAR LEFT
AND THE FAR RIGHT DO NOT HAVE
REMOTELY THE SAME POLITICAL
STRENGTH IN THEIR PARTIES AND
THIS YEAR'S PRIMARY PROVIDE THE
RECEIPTS.
THIS CYCLE, WE'VE SEEN PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE FROM ELECTION LIES AND
THE GOP'S LITMUS TEST.
39 ELECTION DENIERS WON THEIR
HOUSE PRIMARIES, AND THAT'S JUST
IN SIX KEY SWING STATES.
BY COMPARISON, THE FAR LEFT IS
FALLING FAR SHORT.
THE SO-CALLED SQUAD PLAYS A
POWERFUL ROLE IN REPUBLICAN
POLITICS BUT THERE ARE JUST
SEVEN HOUSE DEMOCRATS WHO
OFFICIALLY SUPPORT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE BUT 147 REPUBLICANS VOTED
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION AFTER
THE ATTACK ON OUR CAPITOL.
EXTREMES ARE USUALLY LOUDER THAN
THEY ARE LARGE.
AND GET THIS, JUST 12% OF
DEMOCRATS AND DEM-LEANING
INDEPENDENTS DESCRIBE THEMSELVES
AS MEMBERS OF THE PROGRESSIVE
LEFT, ACCORDING TO A 2021 SURVEY
BY PEW, WHICH TRANSLATES TO 7%
OF VOTERS.
WITH ANY SENSE OF PERSPECTIVE,
THE MAINSTREAM OF DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS AND PARTY LEADERSHIP IS
DECIDEDLY ON THE CENTER LEFT,
NOT THE FAR LEFT.
REMEMBER, THAT'S HOW JOE BIDEN
WON THE 2020 ELECTION, BY
IGNORING THE SOCIAL MEDIA
DISTORTION FIELD AND INSTEAD
APPEALING TO ACTUAL DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY VOTERS WHO TEND TO BE
OLDER, MORE MODERATE, AND MORE
WORKING CLASS THAN TWITTER
FILIBUSTERS WOULD SUGGEST.
NOW WE'VE GOT A NEW METRIC.
IN NEW YORK'S 17th DISTRICT,
REPRESENTATIVE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ENDORSED
PROGRESSIVE
ALEXANDRIA BIAGATI.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT JUST A NEW
YORK THING.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN MICHIGAN'S 11th
DISTRICT, THE MORE PROGRESSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE LOST.
IN OHIO, THE PROGRESSIVE
CANDIDATE LOST A REMATCH AGAINST
A MORE CENTRIST CANDIDATE.
DON DAVIS REPEATED A PRIMARY
CANDIDATE WHO TRIED TO RUN TO
HIS LEFT.
IN ILLINOIS, A HYPERGENERATIONAL
REMATCH FELL FLAT AFTER COLLINS
LOST TO DAVIS BY AROUND 7 POINTS
WHICH WAS ADMITTEDLY BETTER THAN
THE TROUNCING SHE TOOK TWO YEARS
AGO.
IN TEXAS, HENRY CUELLAR NARROWLY
DEFEATED A PROGRESSIVE
CHALLENGER, JESSICA CISNEROS.
ACCORDING TO BROOKINGS, ONLY 34%
OF THE NEARLY 500 DEMOCRATS WHO
HAVE RUN FOR HOUSE OR SENATE
THIS CYCLE CALL THEMSELVES
PROGRESSIVE.
WITH ONLY ABOUT A QUARTER
RUNNING ON POSITIONS LIKE DEFUND
THE POLICE OR GREEN NEW DEAL
WHILE LESS THAN 2% IDENTIFY AS
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT OPTICS,
THOUGH.
EVEN IN CALIFORNIA, WE'VE SEEN
DEMOCRATS POLICING THEIR
EXTREMES AS IN THE RECALL VOTES
AGAINST FORMER SAN FRANCISCO
D.A. CHEA BOUDIN.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS, FOR
EXAMPLE IN OREGON A CENTRIST
CONGRESSMAN LOST HIS PRIMARY TO
A MORE PROGRESSIVE CHALLENGER.
LIKEWISE, SUMMER LEE WON
NOMINATION FOR PITTSBURGH AREA
HOUSE SEAT AND WORKING FAMILIES
PARTY CANDIDATES HAVE BEEN
RACKING UP WINS WHICH COULD
IMPACT BIGGER TICKET RACES OVER
TIME.
BOTTOM LINE, PROGRESSIVES HAVE
MORE CULTURAL POWER THAN
POLITICAL POWER RIGHT NOW.
DESPITE ALL THE NOISE ABOUT THE
FAR LEFT TAKING OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE 2022
PRIMARY RESULTS SHOW THAT'S NOT
ROOTED IN REALITY.
IF YOU'RE STILL TRYING TO GET
YOUR HEAD AROUND WHAT'S
HAPPENING, LIS